all right here we are on overtime uh
we're on
we really on CNN Now CNN what did they
go nuts we're putting us on there but no
we're I'm thrilled the world needs a
good CNN so I'm very happy that we can
help out any way we can uh so we have
Brett Stevens from The New York Times is
back Congressman Ruben Gallego and the
chief of police of Minneapolis not
anymore right
Rondo I love that name don't have his
jumper no you don't so the course first
question is for you do police need
better training in de-escalation tactics
obviously a question on a lot of
people's mind this week you know the
actuality is that uh police are getting
some of the finest training uh that they
can possibly get I think when situations
occur like in Memphis uh it certainly
makes people want to Resort too well
it's the training and at some point in
time we just have to call it it ain't
the training it's the character of the
individual doing this thing
really
it looks like the training sucks too
though sometimes
you're constantly improving training
seriously okay but like why Always
firing the whole clip you know I mean I
I remember reading some statistic I
forget what year it was maybe it was
like 10 15 years ago like the entire
nation of Germany like the police shot
89 bullets in a year
whereas like that's like one
one instance and they're all just firing
the whole clip it seems like once the
firing begins there's no like okay they
are you know police departments are
really doing a a much better job in
terms of of use of force training the
de-escalation piece is the critical most
important piece because we never want
our officers to get into a situation
where they may have to use deadly force
but actually the training uh is is
really good we just have to really start
making sure we're focusing on the
quality of the individual who's wearing
that uniform okay so this is for you if
you uh by the way if the people who are
seeing this for the first time these are
the these are from the people oh boy but
these questions I don't even know what
these questions are I really don't sound
like a magician here but uh we we've
never met halfway uh this is this is for
you representative Gallego why are
Republicans gaining ground with Hispanic
voters oh oh yeah yeah look it depends
where it depends where what's that
you're talking about in Arizona that's
not the case in Florida it's definitely
the case in Texas nationally I think it
is mix it's a mixed bag the reason why
Trump did better even after they're all
rapists yeah
in 2020. what the heck is the biggest
point that uh the reason why this is
happening is because Democrats also need
to respond to the fact that Latinos are
working class and they have aspirations
they want to be rich they want to be
small business owners they want to own a
home and a lot of times we just kind of
gloss over there and we treat them as if
they're just any other voting
demographic if we don't talk to them we
don't actually deliver programs for them
you will start losing them first you
lose them to non-voters to and then they
start voting for Republicans because at
least they have some other Vision but it
has to be an active campaign we actually
have to talk to them about the American
dream about how they be part of the
American dream and sometimes we don't do
that and I and that's how we end up
losing but it's also because
it's also because
Latinos think for themselves I mean we
have this like oh you're you belong to
demographic X so you're a natural
constituency for party y that's just not
the way in which people operate they're
not they're not like Oh I'm a
demographic and therefore I must vote
for this this particular party I mean I
grew up in Mexico City my father was
from Mexico you know even the very term
Latino is so misleading it's so wildly
misleading between well we don't assume
that a Brit is an American is a Canadian
as Australian but we somehow do assume
that a Mexican is a is an Ecuadorian is
an Argentinian is it Dominican uh
and so you know learn what this
community is about I absolutely agree
with with Ruben bit that like it's an
immigrant Community communities are
aspirational and if you have a
Republican party that say we're going to
make it easier for your small business
to operate by not charging you 1.7
million dollars for gold and toilets or
whatever the case may be right they're
going to respond to that Republican
message they're also very Christian and
increasingly Evangelical uh I would say
just a couple of things right I think
it's a it's a big big big misconception
that you know the the Latinos and I do
Congress it's a shared culture is that
uh that they're very religious uh if you
see some of the younger voters
um they are religious in the sense that
they're they're Catholic most of them
but they vote uh in a very very liberal
manner but also Latinos vote in very
different matters it does it depends
when you came here depends how old you
are depends how rich you are or how poor
you are and the the problem with
Democrats is that we do treat them as
one big monolith and we only talk to
them with about two months left in the
election when you really need to be
talking to them from day one and you're
right not assuming just because they're
brown or or have a last name that's you
know ends in a vowel that they're
automatically going to vote for that we
have to earn that we have to earn it and
we have to earn it every cycle
I notice they do there's a lot of
besides what you're talking about that
kind of lumping there's also a lot of
brown and black I hear that term a lot
in when politicians talk
yeah it's a made-up white thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I I feel like they do that because
because obviously someone who comes from
an upper class family in India has
everything in common with someone who
comes from a I don't know a working
class family in the Yucatan I mean it's
all it's only something that essentially
an inherently racist assumption that
anyone who's a slightly darker skin tone
than you has something in common and
they belong in an acronym and it's the
condescension of
I think this is a fatal flaw for the
left this kind of condescending view of
other people you're in you're part of
the bipoc community I think the last
people who know what the bipod Community
is right is the bipart community
I do I do think that there is there has
to be some some you know at least uh
understanding like at least there's an
actual Outreach that's actually
happening and there's an attempt at
least a respect for that now you have
the flip side you know we're trashing
Democrats and then at the same time we
have a party that has not offs have been
great
I grew up in Arizona I was there for SB
1070 I was there for Sheriff Joe Arpaio
and there was a lot of opportunities
where Republicans had an opportunity to
actually reach out to Democrats or to
Latinos and they lost that and they lost
that because of those types of actions
uh and so yeah sometimes there is this
like a language overreach that is
designed to do uh you know try to get
people into your coalition
while avoiding some of the real issues
that are happening but the it happens on
their side and and you know I'll give
you an example I I've you know now that
I recently announced they're running for
Senate you know once a while I'll get a
Twitter you know message that hey well
why am I gonna vote for something that's
owned by the cartels or you should be
president uh you should be a senator in
Mexico like I was born in this country I
served my country and yet I still get
you know accused of not being a true
American and it's disgusting it's coming
from the conservative right
yeah it is gross okay uh this is for the
whole panel is Kevin McCarthy who's your
new leader in congress not yours he's
something yeah he's something
well he's the he's the uh he's the
leader in the house yeah it took 15
ballots right which is almost unheard of
it has Kevin McCarthy already made too
many concessions to Be an Effective
leader of his party well I guess for
people who happen to follow the story
Kevin McCarthy who is a very far right
Republican in my view still was not
conservative enough for like the 20
really really really right people in the
Republican
caucus and they stopped him until they
made him I mean I think they did
everything but make him wear the Viking
hat I I
definitely
uh but like I I think one person can can
get rid of him by objecting to something
he does how can this function because
the Republican Party basically is spit
split between uh reptiles and
invertebrates right I mean
the Marjory Taylor green I know there's
some honorable exceptions I'm
generalizing but what what what Kevin
McCarthy said is I will do anything to
be speaker I will agree to any
compromise at some point he should have
said you know Take This Job Marjorie and
shove it let's give it to Hakeem
Jeffries if this is the way you want to
play and then they would have backed out
and the spinelessness that he the the
the tone he set right there is going to
be the tone of this Congress for the
next two years look it is dangerous like
I'm afraid that he's going to get us
into a debt limit situation where we're
going to end up you know tanking the
world economy because he gave up so much
power to them to have this title right
that it's the title now that's all it is
it has no power more importantly now he
has very zero responsibility but he's
going to end up and the country ends up
dealing with the consequences of that uh
it was not a it was not a great study in
leadership which none of us should be
surprised by but you know it is what
we're dealing with right now let's hope
the economy won't be tanked yes can I
have one question very very quickly
Rondo yes what percentage of cops are
good cops oh
the vast majority of the men and women
who put on that uniform and serve their
communities okay but he said 99.5 in the
show I I don't I don't know if we could
I don't know how it's just a number we
don't figure of speech it was that's not
a figure of speech that's a number it
was intended that way it was intended
that way all right you gotta go thank
you very much